is there any example you can give maybe
without naming names or of someone that
had success and/or or the promise of it
yeah and and you know sort of the green
lights were going off at every
intersection and then stuff stops and
it's a rude awakening
yes actually I can go back to Sean Ryan
again the one who was so promising and
he got a job on a sitcom as soon as he
came to LA and then he didn't work for
six years and what he did is he wrote
and I think that he wrote about 14 spec
scripts and what happened is his scripts
were all good but nothing was getting
him traction and he asked his manager he
said to his manager send me an example
of a script that is getting somebody
work and his manager sent over the
script that had the most buzz at the
time and Sean compared it page to page
and said he'd have you know three things
on a page that were really good but this
one the one that got the buzz every
single beat was perfect and when he
realized that he had not been hitting
the mark he started to write and hit the
mark and in not too long of a time he
got hired on a show and that show led to
another show and then he got he
developed the shield so you just have to
keep working you know and you have to
have a bigger perspective this is just a
business your family the things you care
about those have to be equally important
they don't have to be but I hope they
are equally important in your life I'm
curious how soon into sort of this dip
was he when he finally said let me see
this who whose whose thing is hot right
now I suspect it was about four or five
years in that that happened so he was
only writing that next level of script
for a couple of years I don't know the
exact dates
but I know that story hmm it's
interesting though that cuz that shows
his willingness at some point maybe some
people would have done it at the
two-year mark but to say okay for
whatever reason my thing isn't working
and I've got to look outside my work
because we all see our work with such a
different set of eyes
yes than other people do let's suppose
someone's been in LA for five years yes
they came out blazing hot yeah I've been
here five years yeah haven't been able
to make any real progress are they
better off saying you know what I'm
gonna take a sabbatical back home my
family's there all the people I went to
school with they all love me they're
asking about me you know I think that
really depends five years is a long time
but then there's some people that it
happens in the sixth year I think that
it depends on how strong a stomach you
have for for putting in the work and not
seeing results
five years is a long time but if you
have a vision that's really strong then
I say don't give up but on the other
hand if you have a family to support and
you're going out on auditions and you're
not taking care of your family then
maybe you have to think about that it's
a hard call I have a very close friend
who was an aspiring actor and he'd been
doing it five or six years and we did an
intervention with him his girlfriend and
me and another friend and we said I
don't think it's happening I don't think
the acting thing is happening and he was
kind of devastated and and when he got
over being devastated he said you know
what you're right I don't want to keep
having these crappy jobs and hoping that
I'm gonna make it as an actor and he'd
had some success when he came to town he
was on a television show when he came to
town in fact he was brought to town to
be on a television show and then nothing
happened again for five for five years
and I ended up hiring him to be a reader
and he was so good that he moved up to
being an executive it worked out great
for him and it only happened when he let
go when he let go of that particular
thing
you